marijuana's in our schools is a
disturbing idea to most people but for a
five-year-old girl and her parents in
Santa Rosa California it's a welcomed
relief John Blackstone reports on how
it's making it possible for one
kindergartner to stay in school and
perform at her best at the village
school in Santa Rosa California
five-year-old Brooke Adams is thriving
in kindergarten that's a huge
breakthrough says her mother Janna Adams
she's playing she's learning she counts
to 20 she knows her colors she knows her
letters Brooke success comes in spite of
a debilitating medical condition dravet
syndrome a form of epilepsy that causes
violent seizures that her family once
recorded on video her seizures would be
lasting hours and even in the hospital
trying to get them to stop was very hard
no medication worked until they tried an
oil derived from marijuana we started to
explore THC which is the psychoactive
part of marijuana but that is actually
what her body needs to stop the seizures
but when it came time for Brooke to go
to kindergarten the school district put
up a roadblock our concerns really were
more from both state and federal
government levels were we breaking any
laws in having her medication on campus
cannabis that she takes is an oil
tincture it's just a few drops that we
put in her mouth
and it absorbs wild California is one of
31 states that has legalized marijuana
it is not one of the three states to
specifically allow medical use of
marijuana on a school campus medical
marijuana is legal in California why
could the school district say no you
can't have this medication in school the
school district took the position that
essentially both California state law
and federal law prohibited the use of
cannabis on campus attorney Joe Rogan
who specializes in marijuana law
represented Brookes family in a lawsuit
challenging the school's ban on her
medication if the judge didn't rule in
our favor we could have had to pull her
out of school
the school district was caught between
one federal law that says all marijuana
is illegal and another federal law the
individuals with Disabilities Education
Act and federal law prioritizes children
with disabilities and ensuring that
they're able to have access to education
moreso than other things that the
district was holding on to the
California judge ruled that under both
federal law and California law Brooke
must be allowed to be treated with
medical marijuana in school
I mean she's learning and she's growing
and without cannabis she would not be
that way today a drug many still
consider a danger is seen by Brooks
family as a lifesaver
for CBS this morning Saturday John
Blackstone Santa Rosa California what a
difficult spot for for parents and for
the child to be yeah I did a story with
the metafile players about this idea of
using CBD oil in the same way that she
is using it one of the biggest problems
is they can't research enough because of
the way marijuana is scheduled as far as
it being a Schedule one narcotic and it
just becomes really difficult to see the
benefits you can find when you can't do
the research we saw it on that little
girl's face though yep it's were
currently dead